so from hearing your story a Jay I'm
hearing that you saw the big picture
from a very young age you decided to
graduate early you knew what you need to
do where did that come from I think
there was a natural time limit built
into my life at least I felt there was
when I was very young wife my biological
father passed away from a brain tumor
and I was made to be aware of this as
early as I can consciously remember so
mm I guess having an understanding that
one day you're going to go you know as a
child helps you make your decisions more
carefully at this and uh he died when he
was 30 so I had a goal to where I would
make a feature film that was like sold
in stores and you know seen by the world
to say you know he might say before I
was 30 and I it felt really good to get
compound out because no matter what i
did that you know and yeah so I guess
having a little bit of knowledge of
mortality I was whether I knew it or not
a motivating factor and having a little
bit different picture of how I looked at
the world from an early age but
thankfully I had a you know fantastic
father to figure 2 raised me right i
mean i was there was not very much time
period between when my biological father
passed away my mom remarried to great
man that is my father so i was i was one
of the lucky ones
I probably turned out a lot different my
mom was a single mom for a long time
that's for sure because I would have run
her into the ground she describes
raising me as a water skiing with a
speedboat and and having like holding on
by the one hand so do you think that
helps you book work because you're you
seem to keep constantly busy yeah I like
to stay busy I think it uh you know it's
kind of like people say when you get
older if you don't move your body and
you don't exercise you lose it I feel
it's the same way if you stay idle and
and the film business kind of it's hard
to kick it back in the gear after a
while because it's like you're out of
shape almost I think part of that too is
just the constantly changing technology
just being a cinematographer have to
stay on top of that stuff as well as you
know as your network increases you have
a larger group of people that you know
and are trying to keep in touch with you
have to it's a tough maintenance you
have to constantly check in with
people's the other doing and they're all
off tonight to be involved in projects
and i have a problem where I try to make
everybody happy and say yes as many
things as I possibly can I've been
trying to do a little bit less of that
these days but it's worked out pretty
darn well for me up at at this point
because I've been able to do so much in
a short period of time you know I might
make a couple people angry from time to
time because things aren't done right
off the bat when there's maybe they're
supposed to be but it gets done it gets
done really well so I guess the my
regret would only my only regret would
be that I made somebody upset for a
short period of time but ultimately it's
been beneficial and I think all the
other projects even benefited from it
because I've been able to increase my
skill set from it as well it's a really
hard thing to some assurance a lot of
people as a result of that but what are
your secrets for someone's uh suppose
someone else was asking you know I had
the same problem I don't want to tell
people now
but at the same time I realized that I'm
actually hurting myself by not i think
it's it's something you have to know
within yourself are you capable of doing
the thing that you're saying is too and
I think I you know as a younger person
in my early 20s I could run 3-4 days
without sleeping so i made it took
advantage of that fact and pretty much
did that on a regular basis i would go
hard for like a week and then I've
crashed for the entire day 24 hours
sleep and then same thing next week same
thing follow me and you know it catches
up to you after a while I can't do that
anymore today so I have to be a little
bit conscious of that I get sick if I
don't sleep today that's bad I think I
cracked wrote too many you know sleep
checks and I am a little in debt as a
result of that but uh if I have to I can
go hard still but I I only do that on
projects that are giving me enough back
in order to be able to commit that kind
of time to it also I after having a
movie out now I am you know that video
that you mentioned to me I've watched
that video as a man I did that now what
and so I've been in the place where I'm
kind of thinking like maybe I want to do
other things too I'm not sure exactly
what that is yet but whether it's
commercials or you know a different
aspect of the film industry another
challenge might say I don't know what
that is yet but I also know that I'm
interested and excited about things like
engineering and I have been since I was
a good as well so maybe something maybe
it's a side project that I'm doing maybe
it's something that I can inject
that part of my brain into to get
another another satisfaction out of life
besides just making movies so now that
made movie it's pretty cool but you want
like there's journey never ends you know
like you you arrive at a goal and then
what's next that's always out what I'm
thinking I think alike the last time we
posted something that would talk
together one of my things that I talked
about was moving on to your next project
and that's kind of what I'm always still
thinking about so i think this year i
have six or seven movies coming out that
i shot and they all feel old to me
because they were done a year or two ago
and I'm still thinking about what's next
you know it's kind of a cool cycle that
most professions don't get to experience
where you're constantly doing something
new but things that you've done the
pastor coming back to remind you like
what you've done or they're being
released their being celebrated their
being talked about and it's nice you
know it's exciting it's a little tough
to because some of those things that
you've done a year or two years ago
don't feel like your best to work right
now like when you're doing your best
work and two years logo work comes out
like ha man hope it doesn't most people
aren't going to see that they're going
to look at it as for what it is and
hopefully feel good about it but you
know as an artist you get a little
worried about it sometimes like a couple
movies that have shot or coming out that
char like two years ago and they're good
but I look at the work on my wish I
could I wish I would have done this
better or that better and it's not so
much that I think it's a bad job that I
did I just feel like I know so much more
now I want to add that to it so
interesting stuff always always fun
always knew
you